[Musique]
chevènement lui petit dit oui c'est on y
at il une enseignante
[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes malgré le
dévouement des enseignants
notre école va mal vous le savez 17% des
enfants arrivent au collège sans
maîtriser convenablement l'écriture et
la lecture et tout cela pour quoi
parce que l'école depuis longtemps
victime de la permissivité ambiante n'a
pas reçu de directives claires et ce
sont les enfants des couches les plus
défavorisées qui souffrent des carences
de l'école il est temps de revenir aux
principes républicains et au bon sens il
faut fixer des missions plaire à l'école
d'abord la transmission des savoirs qui
passe par l'acquisition des
apprentissages de base lire écrire
compter
à l'école primaire c'est ainsi que nous
resterons l'autorité des maîtres ensuite
former le citoyen l'éducation civique
doit transmettre les valeurs de la
république
apprendre aux jeunes à aimer la loi qui
protège le faible du fort et puis
l'école doit retrouver sa vocation de
promotion sociale
je multiplierais les bourses et les
préparations rémunérés au concours
nous devons conforter les enseignants
parce que leur tâche est difficile
au coeur de l'école il y à l'exigence
d'égalité permettre à chacun d'exceller
vous savez bien l'école est à la base de
la république
mais pour la reconstruire j'ai besoin de
vous j'ai besoin de votre confiance
[Musique]